the russian president vladimir putin
said again today that he does not want a
war with europe despite describing the
situation in ukraine's donbass region as
genocide it is a false claim it is a
heavily loaded claim and it is a claim
that could be used as a pretext for
invasion the donbass region which we've
highlighted on that map is in eastern
ukraine it has been the scene of heavy
fighting between ukrainian forces and
russian back troops since 2014 and it is
true to say that thousands have died and
millions have fled for safety some of
those into russia
in those intervening years president
putin has granted passports to more than
600 000 people living in the region
thereby effectively making them russian
nationals and so he could in theory send
troops in on the pretense of protecting
those new russian nationals against
these false claims of genocide
so with all that in mind let's have a
look at russian troop movements and what
they might or might not tell us about
the coming days and the possibility of
an all-out invasion of ukraine
now first this video which
caused a bit of a stir around the world
when it was released by the russian
defense ministry it shows tanks from the
southern and western military districts
returning to their bases on the face of
it a good sign but western officials
that i've spoken to give it very little
credibility they point out that there is
a lot of movement backwards and forwards
but most of it in one direction and that
is towards the ukrainian border
so we're now going to show you a series
of satellite photos to explain why they
might conclude that
now here we can see in the first
satellite image the garrison at yelner
in western russia
large amounts of weaponry were moved
there last year including 700 tanks and
ballistic missile launchers but take a
look at this image that was taken on
sunday
and you'll see that has been a lot of
movement and more units have arrived the
next image is an overview of the celotti
garrison taken on january the 12th just
northeast of the ukrainian city kharkiv
now i want you to concentrate on the top
right hand corner of the image because
in the next image taken within the last
48 hours you can quite clearly see
there has been increased activity
and as a final example this time we're
looking at the build-up of helicopters
at a base in crimea 67 helicopters in
total some of them troop carriers some
of them ground attack aircraft any of
them
or all of them could be used as part of
an invasion now that's just a sample of
the satellite imagery and video of
russian troop movements but it does
i think paint a picture and explain why
nato and western officials
remain so concerned